[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in sallys welt heute
gibt es ein türkisches rezept für euch
ganz passend zum ramadan solow kräfte
und zwar bedeutet das wort wörtlich
übersetzt wässriges kräfte kräfte mit
wasser also frikadellen und das ganze
ist ein eintopf und deswegen nennen uns
ebenso und meine mama hat es schon immer
gerne gemacht wo hat man mal macht es
auch ganz gerne und ich glaube jeder der
mal in der türkischen familie zu gast
war in der küche der hat vielleicht auch
schon das zugekaufte gegessen ich werde
zuerst einmal die kleinen frikadellen zu
bereiten das gute daran ist die werden
nicht angebrachten das heißt das haus
die wohnung stinkt danach nicht so
brutal nach frittenbude oder fritten
wurde denn das ganze koch dann einfach
in dem eintopf und das ist echt lecker
und dafür verwende ich jetzt erst mal
250 gramm hackfleisch drei esslöffel
bulgur das ist der feine wohl dort dann
eine knoblauchzehe etwas salz und
pfeffer berg boden kraut oder ihr könnt
auch oregano nehmen und hier habe ich
dann noch etwas mehl später zum wälzen
und das geht jetzt eigentlich ganz
einfach ihr packt nämlich die zutaten
einfach hier in eine rührschüssel
kommt rein dann könnte die knoblauchzehe
dazu pressen und wenn ihr eine
knoblauchpresse benutzt dann müsste sie
auch nicht fehlen das geht dann ganz
einfach so
dann die gewürze rein und dann kann ich
das damit
salz und pfeffer und wie gesagt das
bohnenkraut
ich habe das aus dem garten noch vom
letzten jahr deswegen ist das so ein
bisschen grob und jetzt entweder kneten
oder mit den knethaken einzig verrühren
das war es schon
und dann gebt ihr euer mail einfach in
eine etwas größere schüssel oder in so
tiefen teller denn da kommen jetzt die
kleinen bällchen rein und normalerweise
würde ich jetzt ein eis portionierer
benutzen weil ich damit immer
gleichmäßige portion mache aber ich
mache jetzt wirklich kleine kleine
bildschirm deswegen nehme das einfach so
geformt so eine kleine kugel draus und
gibt sie
das machen sie mir an ella zum beispiel
ganz gern da könnte die kinder dafür mit
in die küche stellen das macht mir als
kind shock bars
[Musik]
so sehen jetzt die fertigen welchen aus
und jetzt brauche ich außerdem noch
etwas olivenöl eine zwiebel etwas
tomatenmark 400 gramm geschälte
kartoffeln etwas wasser zum aufgießen
hier noch die gewürze nämlich
paprikapulver etwas minze zitrone zum
abschmecken und salz und pfeffer jetzt
könnt ihr schon mal auf jeden fall das
olivenöl erwärmen und eigentlich habt
ihr die meiste arbeit auch schon
erledigt denn ihr habt die ganzen
welchen geformt und das ist eigentlich
so dass zeitaufwendig das öl jetzt schon
mal erhitzen und dann die zwiebel fein
hacken und dem öl anbraten
[Musik]
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
hier schon mal die kartoffeln einfach
grob hacken sie müssen nicht so fein
sein die dürfen nicht größer bleiben
und dann war's das schon
[Musik]
und am besten passt dazu entweder ein
bisschen baguette oder türkischer reist
in türkischer reist er passt gut weil
ich den als kind immer gerne dazu
gegessen habe und dann aber immer der
kartoffeln oder zerdrückt und mit der
sauce das war immer perfekt das war
einmal unser essen hat die mama für uns
macht und sobald die zwiebeln glasig
sind das tomatenmark dazugeben mit
anbraten wenn ihr wollt und wenn ihr da
habt könnt ihr auch gerne paprika mark
dazu geben das gab es auch immer super
ich hab das schon bemerkt dafür nämlich
heutigen kleinen morath verfasster so
bajorath und
wenn ihr übrigens ohne
induktionskochfeld habt so wie ich dann
könnt ihr gerne die inflationsrate
nehmen die schützt nämlich euren herz
davor zu verkratzen vor allem wenn man
viel mit gewürzen arbeitet und das
gewürz hier auf dem glas landet und man
dann die töpfe hin und herz- oder der
topf halt irgendwann kochen verrutscht
dann kann es eben passieren dass der
saft ausgeht wie gesagt nur bei
induktion mal induktion nicht heiß wird
da kann mir wirklich hinlangen ohne dass
man sich verbrennt okay ich habe ohne
hände man kann sich schon verbrennen
weil er der topf auch eine rückwärts
aber wie gesagt da schützt es einfach da
jetzt die kartoffeln rein
[Musik]
denn jetzt gerne direkt noch mehr
zitronensaft abschmecken nicht soviel
dazu geben einfach nur so ein bisschen
was recht schon und dann könnt ihr auch
jetzt schon direkt die kräfte bällchen
dazu geben das ganze aufkochen lassen
und dann den herd runterschalten und
dann brauchst du ungefähr 25 minuten bis
die kräfte belchen und eben auch die
kartoffeln gar sind
[Musik]
es sieht jetzt so aus wie beim a8
aufgaben lassen herunterschalten
weiterkochen aufräumen essen das
stadtlauf jetzt ist mein essen fertig
und der drucker dafür probieren denn er
hat mich zum video inspiriert er hat
sich zukünftige wünsche
[Applaus]
haben genauso ausbildung weil man noch
mal die chance auch für das kompliment
wenn jemand sagt das sieht aus wie bei
meiner mama dann ist das ein kompliment
ist
das eigentlich so oder mit reis ist das
immer mit joghurt
ja das kann auch noch und dann nur zu
gut bei uns türken mit gut und wir haben
es immer mit reis gegessen und dann sehe
das jetzt zerstampft
probierte ich hab schon verwehrt ich
habe ein bisschen salz rhein und rhone
so oft wenn wundert's
da dass ich immer reichlich sagte
ein bisschen ich muss auch sagen ich
habe das nur 10 minuten köcheln lassen
dann den herd ausgemacht und der gus
eisen job erledigt eben auch die
deutschen fliegen und der gus eisen
tobte erledigt dann echt so schön den
rest das ziel zog schön nach und
verkosten und zerfällt nicht
sehr gut ich muss sagen es schmeckt
[Gelächter]
lecker schmeckt noch besser
[Musik]
genau nicht aus wird das lecker aber
wirklich mit joghurt schmeckt noch noch
besser ja niemals sagen ja ich esse also
einfach klick gemacht ich hab ich gerade
gerettet wir denken
im rest darunter auch
dann geht es noch mal mit einer anderen
liebe gott ja aber ich bin auch immer
mal das schmeckt mir auch gut vorstellen
also haidle damals an euch alle das ist
für mich so ein typisches gericht dafür
muss ich sagen weil ich es ist nicht so
deftig ja und jetzt so schwer und es ist
so flüssigkeit drin und es ist was
leichtes man könnte jetzt auch noch
karotten mit rein kochen oder portrait
oder anderes gemüse also ich muss sagen
so ist es klassisch ich würde jetzt noch
mehr gemüse reim machen weil ich bin so
ein gemüse freak murat wird zu essen der
will ja eine reinhauen ja ja kann man
ruhig mal ich finde ja da hat man immer
so von allem was dabei und dann hat man
sein gemüse bedarf von talkline gedeckt
also viel spaß beim kochen bis zum
nächsten mal
dann gibt es los
das muss nur rausschauen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]